last night ted cruz was at cpac a
conference for conservatives and he had
an absolutely ridiculous three-minute
segment where he started to talk about
bitcoin and why he loved bitcoin so much
decentralization and the fact that it's
uncontrollable now there's not very many
u.s politicians that understand bitcoin
well enough to talk about it like this
but here's exactly what ted cruz said
during those three minutes so we need to
decentralize we need to break it apart
it's one of the reasons why i am so
bullish on crypto
on bitcoin because it is decentralized
and not controllable and let me give a
fantastic example so justin trudeau
[Applause]
said i don't like me some truckers so
we're going to seize your assets so then
the court
went to try to seize the crypto that was
being given to the truckers and i don't
know how many of y'all saw a letter that
i actually want to read from it's a
letter from a company
bitcoin company called nunchuck here's
part of the letter dear ontario superior
superior court of justice
our software is free
we do not collect
any user identification information
beyond email addresses we also do not
hold any keys therefore
we cannot
freeze our users accounts
we cannot
prevent them from being moved
this is by design
please look up
how self-custody and private keys work
when the canadian dollar becomes
worthless
we will be here to serve you too
that is spectacular
by the way contrast that
to the craven sniveling response of
corporate america
when others when some whiny snowflake
tweets at them think oh my god i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm sorry sir
like god bless you saying to the
government go jump in a lake
that's how our country was founded
that is powerful by the way that is also
why china
recently banned
bitcoin
because they can't control it which is
the exact same reason elizabeth warren
hates bitcoin
the chinese communists and elizabeth
warren they both want to control you
your assets your savings your speech
your life your children every decision
they want to control and so we need to
break up the means of controlling the
citizenry now i gotta say watching ted
cruz talk about bitcoin in this way is
absolutely incredible i didn't expect
the u.s politician to understand bitcoin
this well or be able to talk about it
with such detail to be able to
articulate the ideas of decentralization
and security the fact that no one can
control it no one can censor you with it
those are all things that are important
to bitcoin and ultimately will prove why
every single politician on both sides of
the aisle both republicans and democrats
independents and those subscribed to any
political party they're all gonna be pro
bitcoin because ultimately bitcoin is
american ethos technology it is about
free speech it's about self-sovereignty
it's about individual rights and it is
about a lack of censorship bitcoin is
inevitable and every politician is
eventually going to realize that as well